I’d like to dedicate this talk
to my three children:
Phi, Mack
and Ella Roberta.
(Inhales)
If I stop breathing for two minutes,
I would die.
It is the simplest thing
that all of us do unconsciously
about 20,000 times a day.
So normal
that we forget that breathing
is the essence of life.
My daughter, Ella Roberta,
stopped breathing frequently
and was resuscitated
numerous times by me at home
and in hospital by her doctors,
until suddenly, on the 15th of February,
three weeks after her ninth birthday,
she took her final breath.
Ella was a healthy, clever,
sporty and funny girl.
She had a lot of musical ability.
At the time of her passing,
she already played a dozen instruments.
She was exceptionally good at football,
cycling, skating, swimming and dancing.
Ella was a great writer,
and she was also pretty good at art.
At the time of her passing,
she had a reading age of 15 years.
When she was six,
the simple act of breathing
became the biggest challenge of her life.
I rushed Ella to hospital
28 times in 28 months
when she suddenly began suffering
severe respiratory issues.
She was diagnosed
with life-threatening asthma
at the age of seven.
She was admitted
into intensive care five times
and put in an induced coma
to save her life
when her lungs gave up on her.
It wasn't until after
the first coroner's inquest
in September 2014
that I learned that her possible trigger
of her sudden illness
was to do with "something in the air."
But at that time,
we did not know what it was.
Ella had one of the worst
cases ever of asthma
recorded in the United Kingdom,
according to the pathologist
who carried out her postmortem.
We as a family, we live 25 meters
from the South Circular
in southeast London.
It is one of the busiest roads in the UK.
I later learned that air
pollution around our home
was persistently far above the levels
deemed acceptable by the WHO.
On every walk to school, every bike ride,
every time Ella went outside,
her body was absorbing
invisible, toxic air
spewed out by petrol and diesel vehicles.
A second inquest into Ella’s death,
just in December 2020,
the coroner, Philip Barlow,
he concluded that it was the excessive
illegal levels of air pollution,
not only inducted her asthma,
but it was the highest ever
on the night she died.
As a result of this,
Ella is the first person in the world
to have air pollution
listed as a cause of death
on her death certificate.
Ella's story is unique, I admit,
but her experience is shockingly ordinary.
In too many countries around the world,
air pollution exceeds
what the WHO tells us
is acceptable to breathe.
Fossil fuels, everyone,
they're killing us.
Almost one in five premature deaths
are linked to air pollution
from combustion engines,
coal power plants,
wood burning, ammonia, cooking stoves
and other fossil fuels.
That is 8.7 million people a year
dying from heart attacks, cancer, strokes,
dementia, suicide, depression,
stillbirths and miscarriages.
And that's just the start.
Children are the worst affected
due to their lungs still developing.
Air pollution stunts the development
of lungs and brains.
Scientists, believe it,
are finding soot in mothers placentas,
meaning unborn babies
are directly exposed to the black carbon
produced by motor traffic
and fuel burning.
Like Ella, 93 percent of children
around the world
are breathing unsafe air.
The real tragedy of this is we know
how to solve this public health crisis.
We need to shift from toxic fossil fuels
to clean, electrified public
and active transport.
The second inquest into Ella’s death
made it abundantly clear:
Ella would still be here alive today
if air pollution around our home
had been within the WHO acceptable limits.
Air pollution is an invisible
global pandemic.
It's a silent killer.
You know what,
unless you clean up the air,
you will never resolve climate change.
Do you know why?
It's linked to global warming,
acid rain,
effects on wildlife,
depletion of the ozone layer.
But for me, this is personal.
Eight years after Ella's death,
I still visit respiratory doctors
with Ella’s siblings,
who continue to be impacted
by excessive air pollution.
As my children and I share a genetic link,
we are equally susceptible
to air pollution.
The WHO recently
strengthened its guidelines,
and the evidence shows us
there is no such thing as safe levels.
Every country in the world
must enshrine these new
WHO guidelines into law now.
I'm putting them on notice.
(Applause)
What do I want?
I'll tell you what I want.
I want every government
to guarantee their children
the chance to live full and healthy lives.
To be able to fully and safely breathe.
Breathing clean air
is every child's human right.
Governments have a duty of care
to protect their citizens.
Remember, 350 million people
in the world have asthma,
including me.
(Breathing through inhaler)
The fight to breathe clean air is real.
When I say "Breathe life,"
what do you say?
You say, "Clean air is our right!"
Breathe life!
Audience: Clean air is our right!
RAKD: Thank you for listening.
Thank you very much.
(Applause and cheers)
[Take action on climate change
at countdown.ted.com]